hi all clive stanton here and welcome to
the 2022 warhammer skull showcase skulls
is the annual celebration of warhammer
video games and we're going to kick off
the next week of promotions by taking a
look at some of the awesome titles and
updates on their way soon
including space marine 2 where i voice
the part of titus
of the ultramarines
so sit back strap in for some exclusive
world premieres and reveals
the city of tertiam is under attack
my city
a dark tide of chaos is rising
our best fighters are falling
it's time to try new tactics
something different
something
because you have nothing left to lose
so you're the scum we're counting now
[Applause]
and if it's come to this
then god emperor help us all
[Music]
commander
prepare to engage
the bloom is mutating
new and potent strains now plague the
sector
your knights must be ready commander the
time has come
knights of titan
you are the instrument of the emperor's
will
come at me heretics
failure will cost many souls
the bloom's power here is overwhelming
we will infect the realms of chaos with
our purity
perhaps it is time to deploy more
proactive tactics
each of my brothers
is an army unto himself
a mighty shield against the coming
darkness
hello warhammer fans i'm noah hector
jackson ceo and creative director at
complex games
i hope you enjoyed that trailer which
celebrates the incredible response we've
had since launching warhammer 40 000
chaos gate demon hunters on steam and
the epic game store this past may
for many of us working in the warhammer
40 000 universe has been the realization
of a lifelong passion for the hobby and
alongside the legendary aaron dempsky
bowden we've built an immersive story
set in the grim darkness of the far
future a brutal struggle between the
gray knights and the forces of nergal
led by none other than mortarion himself
we've been overwhelmed by the support of
our community since launch and we love
seeing the stories you've created for
your own squads as they battle against
the chaos plague known as the bloom
as part of this skull showcase we've
commissioned a new requisition from
grand master vardan kai to aid you in
the fight against nergal the ward of
aussies is available for all players
from today
see you aboard the bale fleetict
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
oh
summon the elect accounts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
fighting
[Music]
i goes
uh
welcome mortals
i have something special waiting for you
i hope you don't mind
but i made things a little more
challenging
[Music]
don't worry
you'll learn more
do
[Music]
so working on a warhammer 40 000 license
especially space ring tube is it's an
amazing honor and i'm very excited about
it there are millions of people that
love this franchise
and one of the scary things about this
franchise is that there are millions of
people that love this franchise
we didn't just want to create uh any
third-person shooter we wanted to create
a game that embodied the galactic
warfare that you you come to know from
this franchise it is a passion piece for
all of the people working at sabre you
know these are people who've read the
novels for years who've played the games
and so nobody has higher expectations
than us
i'm playing physically what amounts to
like a super galactic space warrior you
know these guys are two and a half
meters tall they're probably about 500
pounds before you even put the armor on
top of them and their armor
is ginormous how do you recreate that
and then you see it you know suddenly i
am two and a half meters tall and um
it's pretty amazing
most human beings in this world will
never see a space marine they're the
stuff of legends they're known as the
angels of death his angels when one
appears on a battlefield it's like
seeing an angel of god well titus has
you know he's been there done that seen
more than all the other ultra marines
he's an apex predator yeah everything he
does with purpose everything with
intention everything with extreme power
people who've read the books will have
expectations about how spaceman's fight
so that's been our guiding principle
behind the gameplay that we've created
one of my favorite parts of the trailer
release at the game awards was watching
the feedback that people gave afterwards
and i saw all this excitement over just
a tiny few snippets of gameplay and i
just kept thinking wait till you see
what we got for you wait till you see
what's next
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the galaxy is merciless
as life reached to conquer the stars
foes appeared at the turn of every
corner
and many found themselves racing against
the relentless march of oblivion
from the sons of a torn empire brought
low by heresy and treason
to the wandering children of the stars
makers of their own undoing
those who broke their own gods and
forged a path to eternity
and the spawn of savagery hungry only
for more battle
when life turns against itself and
unforgiving devastation seeks to prey
upon existence
who will withstand the whims of fate
bow
[Applause]
greetings blood bowl fans and coaches of
all stripes
you've already had a look at several of
the teams that will be included in blood
bowl 3 when it launches
this year some of you were even able to
try out the game in closed beta
today we're pleased to be able to tell
you a bit more about two teams that will
be making their first appearance in the
game
the chaos renegades and the old world
alliance
what these two teams have in common is
that they're made up of several players
that are usually in other teams so with
the old world alliance you'll be able to
make up a team that includes humans
dwarves halflings and the famous tree
man support
this team combines the flexibility of
the humans with the resistance of the
dwarves
and if you still need a bit more punch
you've got the tree man who can really
block a zone
but make sure you manage the different
parts of your team correctly though
basically the humans tend to refuse to
pass the ball to other players and the
dwarves play very independently which
might make you use up too many rerolls
we had fun designing new unique
customization options for this team with
markings from both the human and dwarf
teams so there is a single team look
rather than different ones
and this is especially obvious with the
tree man who has a really unique look
[Music]
the chaos renegades for their part are
an unlikely alliance of humans dark
elves skaven and green skins alongside
the big guys of chaos
one small point that sets this team
apart is that it can recruit up to three
tough players so they really are
devastatingly strong and intimidating
because of their allegiance to the gods
of chaos every player on the team has
special access to mutation skills giving
them a lot of flexibility
bloodbowl 3 has also given us the chance
to highlight a new major game feature
the pitches which have specific gameplay
rules
today we're going to give you an early
look at three of them
the first is the chaos chosen pitch with
mounds of skulls stone pillars swaying
in the magic wind and molten lava it is
clearly a pitch occupied by dark forces
the pitch starts out in a completely
normal way but if one of the players
from either team ever spills blood
during the first half it will draw the
attention of demonic entities
in the second half heat and lava will
make the game a lot more complicated
sprinting players will trip and fall
more easily and some of them may even be
forced to miss entire drives if they
succumb to heat stroke
the second of these pitches is dedicated
to one of the four gods of chaos
nurgle the god of disease decay and
rebirth at first the pitch is dormant
but if any player is ever unfortunate
enough to die on this sacred ground
then the pitch will awaken from its
slumber carnivorous plants and swarming
worms what had been silent starts to hum
with life
fast players are more likely to fall
down and it becomes difficult for them
to interact with the ball encouraging a
slow and defensive game which gives
nurgle's team a particular advantage
[Applause]
a third of these pitches is that of the
dark elves
what's special about this pitch is that
it was built over water but there's more
beneath the waves lurks a monstrous sea
creature and beware if either team
scores a touchdown in the first half it
might stir
a roaring crowd awakens the impressive
tentacled monster during the second half
of the match the pitch is partly flooded
and stunned players will have trouble
coming around the players will also have
to move more slowly in order to avoid
the monster's tentacles so
now i just like to say i hope you all
have a great day great matches and of
course a little bit of luck with the
dice
we hope you have enjoyed all these new
features
we genuinely can't wait to show you even
more blood bowl 3 holds some more
tremendous surprises for you so we will
say see you soon on the pitch coaches
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're talking
when developing battle sector we set out
to create a definitive battle-scale
turn-based strategy game for the
warhammer 40 000 universe the base game
of battle sector features the age of
crimson dawn campaign set during the
aftermath of the devastation of baal
in april we released our newest faction
the ancient undying forces of the
necrons
and now we're about to unveil the next
faction coming to wage war in battle
sector
the full ranks of the sisters of battle
are coming to battle sector
this summer they will become a fully
playable fleshed-out faction with a
complete roster ready to bring the
emperor's judgment to all who would defy
them the black lab art team are
currently hard at work creating the
models
their goal is to accurately represent
the adapter sororities
and allow the order's militants to purge
all heresy from battle sector
you can expect the sisters of battle to
be available as a dlc this autumn
battle sector is constantly expanding
with free updates as well as new dlc
content these free updates contain new
content and features developed by a
black lab games team that listening to
and constantly working with our
community we are announcing today that
there is going to be new game mode
available on top of the story campaign
single multiplayer skirmish and
planetary supremacy
the ordo mallius have named it the
demonic incursion
the demons of corn are coming to battle
sector in these first stages of their
invasion from the war there will be a
formidable foe that players will
encounter on the battlefields of
planetary supremacy players will be
challenged to face never-ending hordes
of demons
which keep arriving through rifts into
the realm of chaos
tear you hope to survive the inclusion
of a survival mode adds yet another new
way to play battle sector allowing
players to challenge themselves against
the horde and to compete with each other
to get the highest scores
we don't have a confirmed date for its
release yet so expect to hear more from
us over the course of the summer
two months ago when we added the necrons
released a free update that contained
the new planetary supremacy campaign
mode
it's a single-player sandbox campaign
that can be played as any faction
the goal is to dominate the planetary
sectors by conquering the board where
every tower is defended and will trigger
a new battle all battles are fought
across procedurally generated maps and
all featured different ai opponents
we're committed to continually
developing the game by combining the dev
team's plan but also listen to our
community's feedback one of the most
requested features was for more options
for armory progression you've been heard
and it's high on our priority list
we are adding more variety in the armies
that you battle against such as the
demons of corn we're also going to
review and expand the overworld strategy
map
planetary supremacy will be updated
constantly and regularly
these are just the things that are next
on the list
we have further plans to update and
expand the planetary supremacy campaign
and continue to listen to the community
i will let you know about what's coming
next in the next few months
the far future may be grim and dark but
it's bright for battle sector
and we can confidently say that it will
continue for years ahead as well we have
very ambitious plans for battle sector
including new factions new units new
game modes and new features as we
continue to create a definitive battle
scale turn-based strategy game for the
warhammer 40 000 universe just between
you and me iphone whispers on the
aspects of what new forces might be
arriving in the future
i can't say about it yet of course the
official assassin normally will be
having a quiet word if i did
let's just say we've got some really
cunning plans
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr
[Music]
for millennia our esteemed dynasty has
served the imperium of man
bringing forth worlds from the darkness
of the void and into the light of holy
terror
yet i am but an instrument of his will a
sword in his hand
in his great wisdom the emperor bestowed
a sacred mission upon his followers most
true
to explore the frontiers uncharted
to claim relics unthinkable
to thwart threats unnumbered
and i too
come the day i dread
will leave this mission to you my heir
what will your fate be
one of
[Music]
of
service
of heresy
one can only hope
[Music]
it will be better than mine
so
that was quite something and next up we
have some great updates and
announcements on our warhammer mobile
games
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
we are made of fire and metal
we are above all
under the tread of god engines all
things are equal in their insignificance
yet we grant our might and flame to
those with a worthy cause
we fight for the emperor and humanity
we fight for the warmaster
the gods of war shall walk
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the realm of light the balance of
nature is stably preserved
but dark powers are lurking
disease
i think it is time to brighten up this
battle
[Music]
[Music]
a valinor the stoneheart king has
entered seoul arena
bringing some light to the battlefield
the new captain will introduce the
lumineth realm lords
[Music]
like all seoul arena captains avalanor
has a unique trait elder wisdom
once dropping to low health he will get
an extra free unit space in order to add
the perfect unit when it matters the
most
he won't start off with a lot of gems
but his starting unit will be a more
expensive one
the avalon or unit pool is unique in the
sense that he is not only able to use
most of the known order units but also
the new luminaire faction
living in
the realm of light the luminesce are
gracefully mastering both mind and blade
lords of the arcane they harness the
power of light wind and earth into
artful weapons of war
you're able to go for a more greedy
playstyle with this captain if you are
willing to take some risks in the early
game
the extra unit spot goes well with
building more active synergies than
usual in the late game
master your economy and a valinor can be
a real cash cow
since valinor's trait isn't active from
the start he has to be careful not to be
overrun by aggressive captains
but if timed well he can be able to
utilize low health to pick first in the
bonus rounds while at the same time
increasing his army size by dropping to
low health
if winning is not enough for you avalon
or have some breathtaking cosmetics to
show off while crushing your opponents
are you ready to light up the battle
this time boys
[Applause]
well
there you go
i certainly didn't disappoint
you can learn more about all of the
games featured in the showcase and where
to play or pre-order them by visiting
warhammer community.com forward slash
skulls
and while you're there don't forget to
check out all of the warhammer video
games that are running promotions for
the next week so if you've been thinking
about taking a digital dive into the
grim darkness of the far future or the
savage frontiers of the mortal realms
so maybe now's the time
thanks for watching
[Music]
you